what we're going to do in this video is
try to think of the chain of events that
would happen if the supply of loanable
funds were to increase in the united
states and the way that that could
happen is let's say the federal reserve
were to so to speak print money and then
use that money to buy
treasuries in the u.s so it's inserting
those federal reserve notes into the
quantity of loanable funds
well what would happen is that the
supply of loanable funds would shift to
the right so
our new supply would look like this
would look like this i'll call that s
prime and then we'd have a new
equilibrium price of those funds which
we would call our real interest rate
so then we get to r
prime
so our real interest rates have gone
down and we have a higher quantity of
money that is being loaned q prime
but what would be the effect of that
what would be the effect of that
relative to other countries and i'm just
picking japan here as another country
but this could be the case with many
other countries where they have
relatively free flows of of goods and
financial capital and to help us think
through that i drew the balance of
payments for each country and the
balance of payments is made up of the
current account which is talking about
the flows of goods and services and then
you have what's sometimes called the
capital account sometimes the capital
and financial account which is talking
about the flow of uh oftentimes you
could think of it as financial
investment or investments of some kind
or the flow of funds so pause this video
and think about what would happen
well if the real interest rates go down
in the united states and we're assuming
that all else equal in every other
country well then you have a situation
where in japan the relative real
interest rates are now higher so
relative
relative
real
interest rates
interest
rates
are
higher
now in general people might want to say
hey if i can get a higher or higher than
before relative real interest rate it
might not be absolutely higher but it's
higher than it was before relative to
the united states well that might
increase the financial flows from the
united states to japan
and so you might have some more people
not everyone but some more people than
before who want to take their dollars
convert it into
yen
and buy
buy financial assets in in japan where
they can get that relatively now higher
real interest rate
well if these folks are converting from
dollars to yen what's the immediate
effect of that
well it will increase demand for the yen
and so the price of the n in dollar
terms will go up or another way to think
about it is this is going to cause the
dollar
to depreciate
depreciate
relative
relative
to the yen so we're just going to put
that aside right over here because this
is going to have other implications but
that dollar it use it's used to buy yen
and then those investors will will maybe
buy japanese bonds
and so what's happening well we're
talking about the transfer financial
assets and so in the united states the
capital and financial account that will
go down
this will go down you could think of it
it is being
debited
and in japan they are getting they are
getting an increase in financial assets
people are investing more in japanese
bonds however you want to think about it
and so that increase in funds that goes
up and so this is getting
credited
now in other videos we've talked about
how over time the balance of payments
tend to balance out if one side is
getting debited the other side is
getting credited or vice versa so how is
that going to work out in this situation
well that all goes back to the fact that
the dollar has depreciated relative to
the yen if the dollar depreciates
relative to the n what is that going to
do
well now
american goods
american
goods
are
relatively cheaper
relatively cheaper or cheaper than they
were before
cheaper
in japan
and that's hard to read and japanese
goods
more expensive
more expensive
in
the u.s
and so what is going to happen
well in that situation that means that
the u.s is going to export more to japan
their goods are now
are now cheaper in japan japanese goods
are now more expensive in the u.s so
they're going to buy
fewer
japanese
japanese
goods
and sell and export
export
more
american goods american
goods
and so what's going to happen on our
current account well if you're exporting
more that means your current account
goes up it is going to be credited
it is going to be credited
and then the opposite's going to happen
to japan relative to the u.s it's going
to export less and import more so its
current account is going to be
is going to be
debited
now
economies are complex things and what
i've just done is a little bit of a
simplification but these are the general
trends that you would expect other
things that you might expect is well if
you have this flow of of financial
capital into japan
well that might increase their loanable
funds and so their real interest rate
might eventually go down and all of
these cycles would keep going and
reverberating back and forth over time
but this is the general chain of events
that you might expect that the re the
interest rates in japan will become
relatively higher and so you have the
flow of financial funds going from the
u.s to japan in the process when they
convert from dollar to yen the dollar is
going to get cheaper the yen's going to
get more expensive
the american capital and financial
account goes down because you have this
net outflow of financial funds but
because of the depreciation of the
dollar the u.s is now importing less and
exporting more
now a question is is is this good or bad
for either country well it depends what
the country's goals are this might be
good for the u.s if their goal was to
export more american goods or it might
be bad for the u.s if they said hey now
japanese goods are more expensive and
maybe they're dependent on some type of
japanese goods
in some way shape or form that might not
be the case with the u.s but in another
country let's say they're dependent on
oil from other countries or they're
dependent on military hardware from
other countries and if those things
become more expensive that might or food
that might make it a lot harder for
their citizens so it's an interesting
thing to think about uh whether this is
good or bad and how all of these things
fit together